>>> SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
THAT COULD BE A FUNNY SKETCH.
>> THANKS, MAN, YEAH.
HEY, WHY DON'T WE CELEBRATE WITH
A GLASS OF RED WINE.
>> OH, MY SHIRT.
NOW I'M GOING TO LOOK LIKE A
SLOB FOR THE DATE I HAVE
TONIGHT.
>> DON'T YOU HATE WHEN THIS
HAPPENS? I WISH THERE WAS A
SOLUTION TO THIS VERY COMMON
PROBLEM.
>> WHAT'S THAT?
>> I SAID I WISH THERE WAS A
SOLUTION TO THIS VERY COMMON
PROBLEM.
>> WELL, NOW THERE IS, THE
PLIRT.
THE SHIRT MADE OF 100% PLASTIC.
>> THAT'S PLASTIC?
IT LOOKS LIKE A REGULAR SHIRT.
>> I KNOW IT DOES, BUT IT MEANS
SPILLS AND STAINS RINSE RIGHT
OFF.
>> GUYS, WHAT'S GOING ON?
>> THANKS TO MARTIN'S PLIRT, HIS
DATE NIGHT JUST TURNED INTO A
SEX NIGHT.
MAN, THEY'RE COMFY.
HEY, MARTIN, IS THIS COMPANY
LOOKING FOR INVESTORS?
>> THEY NEED INVESTORS BAD!
BECAUSE THEY'RE SO IN THE RED
RIGHT NOW.
>> AUSTIN?
>> YOU WANT ME TO INVEST IN YOUR
COMPANY.
>> AND WOULD YOU BELIEVE US IF
WE TOLD YOU THAT THEY'RE GOOD
FOR THE ENVIRONMENT?
>> PLASTIC SHIRTS?
>> NO, BUT WE WERE HOPING WOULD
YOU BELIEVE THAT.
TRY ONE ON.
>> IT'S LIKE A PHONE CASE.
>> WE GOOGLED AND WE KNOW YOU
HAVE ENOUGH MONEY.
>> GUYS, I CAN'T MOVE MY ARMS IN
THIS.
>> SURE YOU CAN.
WATCH ME WATCH THIS CUP.
I ALMOST HAD IT.
>> THEY'RE STYLISH, STAINPROOF
AND NOT FOR PREGNANT WOMEN.
>> WHAT WAS THAT LAST ONE?
>> SLEEK, LIGHTWEIGHT AND
INTERNAL TEMPERATURE OF 110
DEGREES.
>> THAT'S WHY I ALWAYS WHERE MY
PLANTS.
>> AND THEY SELL PLIKINIS.
>> WHY ARE YOU TALKING LIKE
THIS?
>> BECAUSE WE NEED THE MONEY,
MAN!
WE MAKE $30 A VIDEO.
>> HOW DID YOU GET THE MONEY FOR
THE PLOTHING?
>> I GOT THE HELP FROM MY GIRL.
>> YOU'RE DATING LIZZO?
>> AND BY THE WAY, I'M NOT
WEARING ANY PLANTIES.
>> THESE ARE DANGEROUS AND
INSANE.
THEY DO NOT BELONG IN THE OFFICE
OR ON THE STREETS.
THEY BELONG ON THE RUNWAY!
♪ ♪
>> PLIRTS.
>> PLIRT.
>> LOVE MIGHT AND CHEMICAL, BUT
THEN AGAIN, SO IS PLASTIC.
>> IN STORES NOW.